bene tutti ragazzi dice questo nuovo
video sono file ai visitatori
il parkour con il nostro amico pietro
come tv il video buona visione
ma che cosa devi fare qua saltare
subirla
ma si passa in mezzo no questo male in
un piano che in mezzo a noi non si fa se
penso che si passa lato tutto sporco di
miele vai vai zuccherino bravo sei
capace madonna come sono bravo anch'io e
tanto metti pato non so se vengo preso
niente ma non si può fare sta roba che
si rendono conto del fatto che non si
può fare perché mai saltare scusa con la
gambe grazie e il problema è che ce l'ha
fatta ci ho fatto l'ho fatta non so come
non so che romanda che ma non è vero lo
giuro di un'amica e sano fortissimo non
sono anche come ho fatto ma non fa
niente all'amica questo miele sliding
cioè devo fare tipo di skateboarder lima
e di madonna che bravo bravi rossonero
però però non era così male una così
mario vada o dio ha migliorato amiche 26
nov aspetta aspetta che io quanto hanno
un posto da romio che gli fa dire su
esaltiamo diventati due amiche e molto
chic il miele perfetti poi non canon
cadermi bravissimo fortissimo troppo po
di credibile e credibile madonna
ragazzine del parkour ragazzi
concentrations concentrations piena come
si fa qua spetta che fa a guardamiglio
dico domani tragico domani domani fermo
da un aspetta amiche ray che ho finito
così farmi aiuto e quell'altra pa come
l'altra parte dei vigili dare preso meno
male
slater vado ce l'ho fatta ma mi ha
spinto tu hai a lei scritto tweet a ecco
perché sono uscito ma facciata prego
prego e quindi e quindi mi sento nella
fede mentre sta andando a fuoco tra
l'altro incredibili però sposa di no
guarda che mi vorrei che guarda il caso
agisce può darti una mano csv cvd ma va
a cagare sono due ore che hanno regalato
ma kg subito con chi l'ha visto ma
smettila aia via dai madonna meno male
due ore nel buttarsi nella lava per
trovare passaggi segreti bene cioè donna
è stato livello pensa è stato uno dei
livelli più difficili ragazzi perché coi
tagli non lo vedi ma introvabile quel
regalo è incredibile ho visto ovunque
amiche o letteralmente contro dovunque a
questa guerra sostenuto che ce ne sono
solo miglioramento che un po fa
giustizia un passaggio amiche notiamo
suonando suonando sopra le grate
perfetto yes
sì ma se cadiamo dobbiamo rifarci tutto
questa cosa io giuro che mi vendicherò
un giorno fa nella sala alla fine
l'ultimo livello guarda prega per
arrivare alla fine prima di me perché mi
butti altri errori ma se alla fine
arrivò prima io guarda e la figlia a san
carlo frigato bellissimo ma di rieti
cioè si sa all'ultimo livello c'è una
roba che per sbaglio ti porta al primo
no come come si chiama getting over it
del gioco e ting over in o il serpente
madonna la dinamica più brutta mai
inventata in biologia
tommy che ti aspetto qui va bene ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ha fatta
va bene arrivo si fa qui non lo so ma
immagino chiudeva a saltare sulle zucche
perché non so questo presentimento ai
poeti salutiamo magari gli ex allora
tutto giusto sai che non so dov'è andato
a porta ok non lo so aiuto da qua
bisogna no però non lo so ce l'ha fatta
solo fortissimo vado in una bellissima è
di riandare qua si è farlo come se non
ci fosse un tetto in due mai sino allora
questi salti incredibili allora c'è una
catena fermo fermo ricerca della miche
allora qualche ma c'è una catena che tu
la prendi inchiesta e quindi comunque
sento un bordello a destra mi facevano
comunque vinto ma lo faccio normale se
si prova bravissimo le così mi sono
piegato madonna raga che bello che sogno
non so dove sta andando però in compenso
pronto buongiorno giro strano ho capito
amiche vieni vieni gli ordini li cioè
l'ho trovato trovarli i vini con 201
quei due tridenti affiancati trovami che
non girava mammi che dietro di te
ecco tv non ti vedevo guarda noli sotto
da è esatto ma non vedo c'era un buco
infatti diceva ma scusa
era molto strana come colpo meno male
chuyen è bene o il buon vecchio slime il
buon vecchio o c'è qualcosa qualcosa che
dietro agli grazie controlla meglio
nostro controllo
ma non c'è niente c'è un po da bisogna
veramente passato i quali sarà in cima
no no no no no dove si dove amy lee
porta non so qui si fanno arrivare è un
passaggio a piedi si guarda parlamento
ma come ho fatto un giro incredibile ha
detto dove come si potrà rivedere ci
rivedremo cile mentimi che non ho capito
e ci ho capito se l'aspetta editi o
arrivati non farle di lega perché
saranno di scappare questa parte di
dovremmo essere almeno in due amiche
perché dobbiamo supporre l'accento
kapisa capito ravo bravo bravo
bravissime e ha capito tutto vieni qua
da adesso qua al casinò però ha qualche
chi sono mica bene ma se che di qua mi
sono pagato personale si spinge vivai
provaci bravissimo ma dalla sua
fortissima fortissimi
adesso è stato difficile molto difficile
questo è ma non ho capito cosa devo fare
stare a destra li pi porco del demonio
rega porco del demonio porco porco del
demonio porco maledetto schifoso laico
del demonio sposo di quello che sta in
frigo l'altro ieri e che ancora in frigo
bravo grazie è bravissimo
ok se trovato qua dei nice
cioè fornire grazie
l'ultimo salto è stata la picchiata che
mi ha dato invece non posso più che bene
no non puoi farlo trentesimo livello
cioè e di che butti pato seriato bravi
bravi ce lo vedete voti fare coi
corneille con le piatta piattaforma di
portanza no però non fu di se non c'è
niente però arrivano tutto fortissimo
non so neanche cosa stai facendo dove
sei come sei koper che ci sei amiche io
mi sono stufato perché non so come abbia
quando davanti hai un po pazze matto
poco mai fatto un giorno solo dalla
sinistra
e stato bellissimo ti ho visto passare
ai 300 all'ora morente è stato troppo
vivo non capisco ma io non so neanche
dove sto andando io penso che va fatto a
caso è totalmente a caso vedevo un
blocco di saltavo sopra ok ok ok è vero
non lo sai venendo veramente una delle
bellissime dove cazzo si va
no perché è di te non si capisce un
cacchio per ma non si capisce non si
capisce dove devi arrivare come
arrivarci perché arriva non si capisce
niente
e giusto giusto mix giusto di verde
poema da che parte destra sinistra dove
detterà da sinistra e poi giù invece no
non è possibile guarda sono cascati di
quello di fianco al bene wang uno dei
sinistra toglie guarda era giustamente
si guarda c'è questo quadro era andato
io sì poi dirittura ok invece meno meno
male che tanto sono cadute un blocco
poco sotto perché sono a questo punto
dovrei farmi tutto proprio ma non ce la
fa dice poi il filtro c'è mira di mare
quindi ragazzi questa la particola amico
pietro grazie per aver partecipato al
video amiche ea la prosecuzione di mike
ha saputo di fiducia ce l'avrai capito
non me lo hai capito ragazzi
[Musica]